Königs übertragen und natürlich auch
analysieren aber es gibt noch weitere
wichtige Themen heute zum Beispiel die
Rede von Ulla Scholz live gegen 10 Uhr
vor dem Europäischen Parlament auch das
sehen Sie natürlich live bei Phoenix
anlass ist der heutige Europatag und
Ursula von der Leyen die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin sie ist in
Kiew eingetroffen trifft den der
ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski auch
das wird im Laufe des Vormittags bei uns
ein Thema sein schauen wir aber jetzt
nach Moskau zur Militärparade und zur
Rede Putins die gleich stattfinden wird
ich hatte schon angekündigt bei mir im
Studio zwei Gäste Roman concerenko sie
beobachten Jahr Russland und die Ukraine
für die Deutsche Welle was können wir
von dem heutigen Tag von der Rede
erwarten haben sie da irgendwie eine
Anhaltspunkte gefunden in den letzten
Tagen was Vladimir Putin sagen wird
nun
das ist ein sehr ungewöhnlicher Tag vor
allem deshalb weil es schon das zweite
Jahr des Krieges in der Ukraine gibt und
die ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht es gab
heftige Kämpfer zuletzt und was
besonders ungewöhnlich ist dass es in
Moskau angeblich einen drohneneinschlag
gab direkt auf dem Roten Platz erst vor
wenigen Tagen
aus Sicherheitsgründen also heißt es
offiziell wurden auch einige
Veranstaltungen entlang der ukrainischen
Grenze in Russland ganz abgesagt es wird
keine keine Parade geben die heißt das
unsterbliche Regiment auch aus
Sicherheitsgründen und man erwartet
natürlich von Putin äh wie es weitergeht
kündigt der jetzt eine russische
Offensive an vielleicht ähm das ist
nicht ausgeschlossen oder was passiert
in der Nacht davor wurde gehe von die
ganze Ukraine schwer mit Raketen
beschossen aber die ukrainische
Luftabwehr konnte die meisten davon
abfangen egal Ranz er ist ja ehemaliger
General und auch für die NATO 2007 bis
2010 eine der Rang größten generäde der
eine krankhöchsten deutschen generiere
gewesen was wird was Erwartung haben sie
an die heutige Militärparade gerade
jetzt noch mal so im Verlauf der letzten
Jahre und eben auch mit im Zusammenhang
des angriffskriegs Russland gegen die
Ukraine also wir hatten ja eine Phase
etwa in den 90er Jahren wo die Größe
dieser Militärparade deutlich verringert
worden war zur Zeiten von Jessi und
seitdem Putin an der Macht ist wird das
wieder hochgefahren insbesondere auch
die letzten Jahre hoch gefahren und wird
ein Vergleich ziehen müssen zu der
Militärparade zu seiner Rede vom
Vorjahren ja voriges Jahr hat er
versucht den Zusammenhang zwischen den
russischen Soldaten in der Ukraine zu
den kriegswetter Waren des Zweiten
Weltkrieges herzustellen und die sollten
sich genauso fühlen wie die kriegswetter
waren ich erwarte das heute in ähnliche
Richtung er wieder sich äußern wird ich
hoffe dass es nicht zu Beschimpfung
kommt von seiner Seite in diese Richtung
und da muss man abwarten wie die Parade
sich aufstellt und sie zusammengesetzt
ist ob man möglicherweise das ein oder
andere neue Waffensystem sieht und wie
die das die Sache sich dann noch weiter
entwickelt Herr gonzer Renko was glauben
Sie eigentlich wenn wir jetzt diese
Bilder sehen sind das Bilder die an den
Westen gerichtet sind oder hat die
Parade hauptsächlich den Sinn das
russische Volk zu motivieren hinter
diesen Angriffskrieg zu stehen denn
immerhin das hat ja auch Konsequenzen
für die Menschen dort vor Ort also die
Parade ist in erster Linie nach innen
gerichtet das ist schon seit Jahren so
und noch in Sowjetunion aber seitdem sie
mir Putin Präsident ist seit über 20
Jahren wurde dieses ganze Thema der
Sieges im Zweiten Weltkrieg ist über
Nazi Deutschland das wird sehr stark
propagandisiertisch instrumentalisiert
das heißt ähm das ist sozusagen Staats
bestimmt für Russland und das ist auch
im Kern ein Instrument um diesen Krieg
auch zu begründen denn Russland gegen
die Ukraine führt russland versucht eben
die Brücke zu schlagen zwischen dem
Krieg damals und dem Krieg heute Sie
sich also im Krieg gegen Nazis so heißt
es in der russischen Propaganda sind
Ukraine sein Nazis an der Macht und das
wird täglich in allen mediensendungen
ausgeschlachtet und deshalb ist das hier
was wir sehen in Moskau heute aber auch
grundsätzlich diese ganze Sprache des
Krieges die wird sehr stark verwendet
und ist auch sehr wichtig für für
Russland um eben diesen Krieg weiter zu
führen ja man versucht also ständig hört
man setzte wie damals unsere Väter und
Großväter haben gekämpft so müssen wir
heute das Böse besiegen also diese Sätze
ja mann
Geschichte nach vorne genau
Geschäft zu führen der durch nichts
provoziert war das heißt man kann das
überhaupt nicht vergleichen damals wurde
die Sowjetunion von Nazi Deutschland
angegriffen jetzt hat Russland selbst
sein Nachbarland angegriffen und für
diesen Krieg schon seit wie gesagt über
einem Jahr mit sehr hohen Verlusten was
besonders ist noch an diesem Tag an
diesem heutigen also zwischen äh das
zweite Mal während des Krieges das
sozusagen der 9 mai äh jetzt feiert als
ähm in diesem Jahr das Tag letztes Jahr
gab es sehr hohe Erwartungen vor allem
in Richtung Mobilisierung Putin Russland
Präsident Putin hat es nicht gemacht
damals sondern er hat es ein halbes Jahr
fast ein halbes Jahr später angekündigt
und das zeigt
damals hatte er auch andere
Vorstellungen vom Krieg er ist damals in
seiner Rede auch relativ vage geblieben
ja er hat kurz nur über den Krieg
gesprochen wir werden abwarten was er
heute sagt
russland hat ganz offensichtlich gehofft
also vor diesem Tag noch die Stadt
bachmut in der Ostukraine im Gewitter
einzunehmen es ist nicht gelungen obwohl
die Stadt fast vollständig zerstört ist
und von russischen truppenkontrolliert
aber die Ukraine haben das verhindert
dass das propagandace dann auch
ausgeschlachtet wird Herr Rahms das sind
ja jetzt Bilder hochglanz-bilder
sozusagen die uns da präsentiert werden
das erinnert mich so ein bisschen noch
ein paar raten äh zu Sowjet Zeiten
beispielsweise das hat mit dem Krieg den
Russland momentan in der Ukraine gegen
die Ukraine führt nicht zu tun wo
Jahrzehntausende Menschen sterben ist
das auch ganz bewusst jetzt dieses eine
propaganda-show und sozusagen diese
diesen Schrecken des Krieges da zu
verschenken
wie gerade schon gesagt worden ist die
Bilder die Parade richtet sich nach
innen und praktisch Solidarität im
Bereich Russland in der Bevölkerung der
Russischen Föderation der Bevölkerung zu
erreichen und zu erzeugen es soll
sicherlich auch eine gewisse Wirkung
nach draußen gehen nach dem Motto bei
uns geht das Leben normal weiter also
der 9 mai wird gefeiert in Russland wie
er in den vergangenen Jahren auch seit
Putin wieder verstärkt gefeiert worden
ist von da sind die Signale doppeldeutig
was die Parade selber angeht es ist ein
bisschen surreal sage ich baue aus
meiner Sicht wenn ich weiß dass
russische Soldaten in der Ukraine im
Schlamm liegen in Stellung liegen für
den Angriff gegen bachmut beispielsweise
aber auch gegen andere
ukrainische Städte und wenn man dann
diese Bilder sieht mit den Parade
Uniform ich sag das absichtlich so
akzentiert die Veteranen dabei mit allen
Orten behängt die Sie möglicherweise im
Zweiten Weltkrieg oder noch zum Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieg gehabt haben Putin
platziert zwischen zwei Veteranen das
sind interessante aufmachen interessante
Einstellung die da ist die sich dann
auch nach innen und nach außen richtet
und ich erwarte dass an seiner Rede auch
die Verbindung zum Großen
Vaterländischen Krieg wieder herstellt
und die Ukraine Krieg in einer
Helligkeit die sonderoperation in der
Ukrainer sucht man ja wahrheitsgemäß so
nennen auch in eine ähnliche Art und
Weise wieder einordnen wird aber wir
werden es hören wir hatten ja ich
erinnere mich noch ein bisschen an die
rede ich glaube die hat er im Februar
gehalten dort das war ja auch die große
Rede auf dem Roten Platz da hat er ja
sogar Tränen vergossen diese Empathie
die er dort zeigt erwarten müssen wir
die heute wieder erwarten das ist schwer
zu sagen also er hat schon mehrmals auf
dem Roten Platz gesprochen und ähm er
hat mehrmals diesen Krieg auch begründet
es sind immer die gleichen Argumente ich
nehme an wir werden sie auch heute hören
also er sieht Russland in Krieg gegen
ähm Nazis gegen den Westen und Russland
war gezwungen diesen Krieg zu beginnen
der kriegt sehr schlimm wird er sagen
wir haben Verluste und wir müssen weiter
kämpfen also im Grunde genommen wird er
versuchen weiter die Stimmung anzuheizen
und ein Impuls zu geben weiter zu
kämpfen nicht aufzuhören solange seine
Ziele die er immer wieder mal ändert
erreicht sind ja und das Hauptziel ist
davon bin ich überzeugt ist die Ukraine
als eine politische Einheit zu zerstören
also die ohne ukrainische Unabhängigkeit
die schon seit über 30 Jahre existiert
zu zerstören
wir sehen jetzt noch mal hier die Bilder
vielleicht noch mal für die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer von Phoenix
die sich jetzt dazu schalten das ist die
Militärparade in Moskau zum neuen Tag
Tag des Sieges im vaterländischen im
Großen Vaterländischen Krieg wird
gefeiert unter anderem eben auch mit
Veteranen aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
herums können Sie eventuell auch noch
mal sagen was wie diese Parade jetzt
abläuft nein da habe ich jetzt zur Zeit
keinen Eindruck davon das war ein bei
vergangenen Paraden immer üblich
dass dabei auch neue Waffensysteme
gezeigt wurden ob man das jetzt macht in
dieser Situation kann ich nicht
beurteilen wir werden sehen da müssen
wir uns ein bisschen Geduld fassen bis
die Soldaten marschieren bzw die
Waffensysteme dann wenn welche gezeigt
werden vorbeifahren
zu den Waffensystemen eine Anmerkung das
ist ja hoch gelobt worden aufgrund einer
paradevorgang 7 Jahren der T14 armata
als neuer Kampfpanzer für Russland der
bisher im gefechtgeschehen in der
Ukraine nicht aufgetaucht ist von dem
auch eine Produktionslinie eingestellt
worden ist von daher es gibt auch dabei
solche Paraden ab und zu mal dann den
Hinweis verknüpft mit anderen
Ereignissen und Nachrichten das in
Russland mit Blick auf die Streitkräfte
bei weitem nicht alles funktioniert wir
sehen jetzt gerade Bilder wo der
russische Verteidigungsminister das
Ergebnis
und wenn ich diese Bilder sehe ähm muss
ich an die Ereignisse der vergangenen
Tage denken und das war wirklich etwas
Besonderes nämlich
wurde sehr persönlich sehr brutal
beschimpft von einem gewissen Herrn
prikosin der
Eigentümer einer private Armee sein soll
also der sogenannten wagnergruppe genau
ja die die sich so positioniert als eine
militärische Kraft die besser kämpft als
die russische Armee und prigoren liegt
schon seit Monaten im Clinch mit dem
Verteidigungsminister schön
genau mit dem generalstoffchef grassimo
er wirft ihnen immer wieder Unfähigkeit
vor wird Ihnen vor nicht genügend
Munition zu liefern und vor einigen
Tagen gab es ein Video von ihm wo er
sich aufgestellt hat mit mehreren
Leichen von
nach seinen Aussagen getöteten Kämpfern
von von
wagnergruppe und er sagte diese diese
toten Männer da sein auf dem Gewissen
von Gerasdorf weil sie nicht genug
Munition liefern also dann er hat auch
angekündigt aus bachmund abzuziehen am
10 Mai er sagte wir halten noch Stellung
bis zum 9 mai zu diesem großen Tag und
dann ziehen wir ab wenn wir nicht genug
Munition bekommen und es war schon sehr
ungewöhnlich denn die Sprache die er
benutzt hat war ein first für mich also
ich habe das noch gewesen wenn man sich
das noch mal vergeben werde ich die eben
genauen Kontrast zu dem was wir jetzt
hier sehen nicht der Hochglanz sondern
Soldaten sozusagen oder Männer in
Uniform die da lagen Dutzende von ihnen
und äh nach diesen Beschimpfungen dachte
ich mir es kann doch nicht sein dass der
Verteidigungsminister der so der so
vorgeführt wurde wie schon werden
Entschuldigung wirklich dass der dann
noch immer bleibt oder sein
generalstoffchef also
man muss wenn man ihn sieht muss man die
ganze Zeit daran denken dass er nicht
die Unterstützung der Truppe hat
vielleicht das auch seine Soldaten das
bestimmt mitbekommen haben wie er
beschimpft wurde und es ist für mich
unerklärlich
warum Putin weiterhin zu ihm hält also
es gab schon vorher Kritik Richtung
schöngut weil Russland ja am Anfang des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine nicht die
Ziele erreichen konnte die Putin gesetzt
hat Russland ist damit gescheitert Kiew
einzunehmen in den ersten Wochen und
dann gab auch zwei erfolgreiche
Operationen der Ukraine in Haki von den
Personen im Herbst wo Gebiete
zurückerobert wurden und trotzdem
blieben die beiden Schalke und Garagen
Ämtern das heißt es wird jetzt darüber
spekuliert wie lange noch denn diese
diese diese Episode letzte Parade das
könnte seine letzte Parade sein ja wir
sind jetzt hier noch mal ich weiß nicht
haben sie schon gerassimo gesehen ich
konnte ihn jetzt noch nicht das ist ja
der Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte
der spielt der auch an dem heutigen Tag
eine wichtige Rolle er könnte dabei sein
in dem zweiten Wagen wenn es der erste
Wagen ist mit dem verteilen konnte gar
nicht oft theoretischen im zweiten Wagen
der jetzt rechts versetzt dahinter zu
sehen ist könnte gerassen drin sein
werden jetzt die Waffen Gattung einzeln
abgenommen oder wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen bei dieser Parade also es
gibt eine bestimmte Reihenfolge der
Parade wo zunächst sage ich mal
Armeeeinheiten kommen werden dann kommt
kommen Abordnung der Luftwaffen dann
Abordnung der Marine
wenn Waffensysteme gezeigt werden sind
sicherlich auch stark die strategischen
Raketentruppen mit dabei und ob dann
noch eine Flugschau durchgeführt wird
von Seiten der Luftwaffe mit überfliegen
über den Roten Platz seine Frage die
unter anderem auch aus
Sicherheitsgründen offen ist die wurde
abgesagt auch letztes Jahr also auf
jeden Fall wurde sie nicht geübt jetzt
also geht davon aus dass es keine
Flugschau gibt aus Sicherheitsgründen
wahrscheinlich letztes Jahr hier ist das
Wetter sei unpassen aber es gab sie
tatsächlich nicht was sehr ungewöhnlich
war schon letztes Jahr wobei das Wetter
ja heute wie wir sehen in Moskau
ausgesprochen gut ist also die
Wetterbedingungen könnten da
wahrscheinlich nur eine geringere Rolle
spielen und wir sehen die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind beispiellos
also als sie mehr Putin gesehen haben
wir da kam war ein bodiger direkt hinter
ihm das habe ich selten so gesehen und
da kam noch ein zweiter auch direkt in
der Nähe das heißt nach diesen
vermutlich und wir müssen das immer noch
sagen Anschlägen mit Drohnen auf dem
Roten Platz am auf dem auf ganz in der
Nähe also
sitzt und dort ist jetzt der
Verteidigungsminister ausgestiegen und
meldet jetzt sozusagen wahrscheinlich
sozusagen die Truppen also er meldet
vermutlich an den Präsidenten dass die
Parade fertig ist zu Durchführung es ist
der Präsident der die Meldung bekommt
und dann wird die Parade gleich anfangen
die Musik marschiert glaube ich schon
auf und jetzt spricht
hören gleich die mir Putin und wir
werden das denn im Anschluss auch noch
mal miteinander besprechen was er gleich
sagen wird
beim letzten Mal hatte er glaube ich
eine schusssichere Weste um das davon
können wir heute wahrscheinlich auch
rausgehen
verehrte Bürger Russlands
Liebe Veteranen
Kameraden Soldaten und Matrosen
Feldwebel und schnapsfeldwebel Marine
Oberfeldwebel Fähnriche
kameradenoffiziere Generäle und Admiräle
Kämpfer und Kommandeure der Beteiligten
der militärischen sonderoperation ich
gratuliere Ihnen zum Feiertag zum Tag
des Sieges
ein Feiertag zu Ehren unserer Väter
Großväter und Urgroßväter
die ihre Namen unsterblich gemacht haben
indem sie die Heimat verteidigt haben
ihre Tapferkeit sie haben Opfer gebracht
sie haben die Menschheit gerettet vor
dem Nationalsozialismus
heute ist die Zivilisation wieder auf
einem Scheideweg der entscheidend ist
gegen unsere Heimat wurde wieder ein
Krieg angezettelt aber wir haben dem
international Terrorismus ein
hingegenschlag verpasst wir haben wir
werden auch die Bewohner des dornbas
beschützen und unsere eigene Sicherheit
gewährleisten für uns für Russland gibt
es keine
unfreundschaftlichen oder feindseligen
Länder weder im Westen noch im Osten
die absolute Mehrheit der Menschen auf
dem Planeten und so wollen auch wir
Frieden Freiheit sehen auf der Welt und
Stabilität wir sind der Meinung dass sie
jede Ideologie der Überlegenheit von der
Natur aus schon gesehen abscheulich ist
den Tod bringt aber die westlichen
globalistischen Eliten
sagen nach wie vor dass sie exklusiv
sind sie hetzen die Menschen
gegeneinander auf sie spalten die
Gesellschaft sie provozieren blutige
Konflikte und Umstürze sie sehen Hass
großephobie aggressiven Nationalismus
sie zerstören familiäre traditionelle
Werte die den Menschen zum Menschen
machen
weiterhin
den anderen den anderen Völkern ihren
Willen aufzuzwingen ihre Regeln ihre
Rechte aber das ist eigentlich Raub
Unterdrückung
sie haben offenbar vergessen wozu die
Ansprüche der Nationalsozialisten
geführt hatten sie hatten vergessen wer
dieses Ungeheuerliche totale böse
zerstört hat wer aufgestanden ist für
die Heimat wer sein Leben geopfert hat
für die Befreiung der Völker Europas wir
sehen wie in einer Reihe von Länder
kaltblütig die memoriale an sowjetischen
Soldaten zerstört werden und
niedergerissen werden wie ein echter
Kult von National Nationalisten
geschaffen werden aber das Andenken an
wahre Helden versuchen sie auszulöschen
auszulöschen und zu lügen so eine
Verhöhnung der Heldentaten der Sieger
Generation ist auch ein Verbrechen ein
offenkundiger
der zynisch eine neue Invasion gegen
Russland vorbereitet hat wer dafür
Neonazis aus der ganzen Welt versammelt
hat ihr Ziel und hier gibt es nichts
Neues ist es einen Zerfall unseres
Landes zu erreichen die Ergebnisse des
zweiten Weltkrieges auszulöschen
letztendlich das System der globalen
Sicherheit kaputt zu machen und das
Völkerrechts
sie wollen alle souveränen Zentren der
Entwicklung ersticken
das sind Ambitionen
Hochmut das wendet sich immer in eine
Tragödie das ist der Grund der
Katastrophe die das ukrainische Volk nun
erleidet das ukrainische Volk ist ein
eine Geisel des staatlichen Umsturzes
und des verbrecherischen Regimes und der
westlichen Herren
sie sind Opfer bei der Umsetzung ihrer
brutalen eigennützigen Pläne für uns in
Russland ist das Andenken an die
Beschützer der Heimat heilig wir
bewahren das Andenken in unseren Herzen
wir sollen Tribut auch an den Widerstand
Anfang die tapfer gekämpft haben den
Kampf von der alliierten Armeen USA das
Vereinigte Königreich und anderer
Staaten wir erinnern uns auch an die
Kämpfer Chinas im Kampf gegen die
Japaner ich bin mir sicher dass die
Erfahrung der Solidarität der
Partnerschaft im Kampf gegen die
gemeinsame Bedrohung ist unser
einzigartiges Erbe eine feste Stütze
gerade jetzt wenn
wir uns gegen die gerechte Welt
streben was auf der unteilbaren
Sicherheit fußt gleiche Möglichkeiten
für eine freie Entwicklung aller Länder
und aller Völker es ist sehr wichtig
dass heute hier in Moskau sich auch die
staatsche von freundschaftlichen Ländern
versammelt haben ich sehe ich ja eine
dankbare Beziehung zum Andenken unserer
Vorahnen wir haben zusammen gekämpft und
haben zusammen besiegt alle Völker der
UdSSR haben ihren Beitrag geleistet in
in den gemeinsamen Sieg und wir werden
das immer im Andenken behalten wir
verbeugen uns zu tiefst angesichts des
guten Andenkens derjenigen die im Krieg
gefallen sind im Andenken an die Söhne
Töchter Väter Mütter
Großväter Ehemänner Ehefrauen Brüder
Schwester
Angehörigen und Freunde
ich erkläre nun eine Schweigeminute
vielen Dank
verehrte Bürger Russlands
kämpfen die entscheidend sind für das
Schicksal unserer Heimat wir sind immer
vaterländisch und heilig gewesen wir
bewahren das Andenken unsere Vorfahren
wir verstehen sehr gut was es bedeutet
ihrer würdig zu sein
ihrer Erfolge und Leistungen
wir sind stolz auf die Beteiligten der
militärischen sonderoperationen auf alle
die an der Front kämpfen die unter Feuer
die Front versorgt verwundete rettet es
gibt im Moment nichts wichtiger als ihre
kampfesarbeit
sie sind die Garanten für die Sicherheit
des Landes von ihnen hängt die Zukunft
unseres Staates und unseres Volkes ab
sie erfüllen mit Ehre ihre Pflicht sie
kämpfen für Russland
hinter ihnen stehen ihre Familien Kinder
Freunde sie warten auf Sie ich bin mir
sicher dass sie ihre grenzenlose Liebe
spüren das ganze Land steht geschlossen
um unsere Helden zu unterstützen
alle sind bereit zu helfen
sie beten für Sie
Kameraden Freunde Liebe Veteranen
in jeder Familie werden die Beteiligten
am Großen Vaterländischen Krieg in Ehren
gehalten wir denken an unsere Helden
unsere Angehörigen Blumen werden
niedergelegt an den Gedenkstätten
wir stehen auf dem Roten Platz zusammen
das ist der Boden der an Juri
Mitgliedern
von Peter dem Großen Paraden von 1941
und von 1945
die beteiligtende militärischen
sonderoperation sind heute hier
das sind die Männer
und die auch in der teilmobil machen
kämpfen das sind Kämpfer in Lugansk in
Donezk viele Freiwillige und
Vereinigungen in der Rust Garde am WDF
ist bei MTS und anderer Spezialkräfte
und Behörden ich begrüße Sie liebe
Freunde ich begrüße alle der für
Russland kämpft auf dem Feld der jetzt
auf seinem militärischen Dienst Posten
steht in Jahren des Großen
Vaterländischen Krieges haben unsere
Ahnen bewiesen dass es nichts mächtiger
und zuverlässiger gibt als unsere
Geschlossenheit und Einheit in der Welt
gibt es nichts was stärker ist als
unsere Liebe zu Heimat für Russland für
unsere tapferen Streitkräfte für den
Sieg hurra
[Musik]
so das war also die Rede von Vladimir
Putin die war ja relativ kurz wenn man
das mal so sagen darf nicht ja sie war
kurz aber sie war auch letztes Jahr
nicht sehr lang und sie ist vergleichbar
Waage geblieben das heißt er hat keinen
konkreten Bezug jetzt auf die
Kampfhandlungen in der Ukraine genommen
also hat nicht gesagt also hat keine
Städte erwähnt er hat nur gesagt das was
er immer sagt wir kämpfen gegen den
Westen der uns zerstören möchte das Ziel
sei Russland zur zerteilen und zu
zerstören und ähm unsere Soldaten
kämpfen wie damals im Zweiten Weltkrieg
so kämpfen sie auch jetzt in der Ukraine
überhaupt war sehr wenig von der Ukraine
zu hören in seiner Rede und ähm
kämpfende Truppen sagt er ja sein mit
dabei dieses Jahr ja
also es hat sich nichts geändert aber es
gibt keine gute Nachrichten die jetzt
hätte verkünden können ja und offenbar
ist das der Hintergrund warum er so kurz
und und Waage geblieben ist
aufgefallen die Einheiten so sagte er
das die in der Ukraine im Kampf stehen
noch mal separat begrüßt hat und ihre
wichtige Rolle betont hat und
dergleichen mehr er hat einen anderen
wichtigen Teil in der Rede ich zitiere
der Westen seht Hass ist russophob und
dieses führt dazu dass es zu diesem
Krieg gekommen ist das heißt der geht
weiter in seiner Schuldzuweisung
gegenüber dem Westen er hat die NATO
zwar nicht Express ist werbes erwähnt
aber hat vom Besten gesprochen und er
hat gleichzeitig auch gesagt dass der
Westen das System der friedlichen
Zusammenarbeit ist wirklich ein
Zusammenlebens kaputt macht was er nun
in meinen Augen eine völlige Tatsachen
Verdrehung ist und in keiner Form der
Realität spricht entsprechen er ist der
Aggressor er hat den Krieg angefangen
völlig überflüssigerweise die gerade ja
schon gesagt worden ist von daher
eine Verkehrung der Wahrheit was der
ganz interessant ist er hat ja nicht die
gesamte Ukraine angesprochen und hat
gesagt wir wollen sie erobern soll er
hat gesagt wir wollen den Don Bass
beschützen ist das vielleicht schon ein
kleines bisschen zurückrudern das
Russland mit dem jetzt zufrieden ist was
sie erreicht haben nein das würde ich
nicht sagen also ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass Russland weiterhin daran
interessiert ist bzw das Hauptziel ein
Regime Wechsel in der Ukraine
herbeizuführen und die ähm auch
einzunehmen das heißt Russland geht
weiter davon aus dass es ein langer
langjähriger Krieg sein wird
dankeschön erstmal soweit wir reden
gleich noch weiter ich begrüße nämlich
jetzt in Moskau die ARD Korrespondentin
in Moskau inaroog herzlich willkommen
Frau Ruck sie hatten sich die Rede von
Wladimir Putin ja auch mit angehört
können Sie schon sagen wie das auf sie
gewirkt hat
wenig überraschend ehrlich gesagt ich
habe ein wenig gerade noch ihrem
Gespräch noch zugehört ich stimme dem
größtenteils auch zu was für mich
bedeutsam war dass er gleich zu Beginn
der Rede noch mal wieder die parallele
gezogen hat die vermeintliche zwischen
dem Krieg damals und dem Krieg heute
damals wie heute sei es gegen Nazis
gegangen das muss man also offenbar den
Leuten hier immer wieder einen impfen
damit sie das ganze auch gut finden und
verstehen was ich auch außerdem
bedeutsam fand war noch mal der Schluss
der Rede es sind ja doch einige
Vertreter von gos-staaten von mit
Russland befreundeten Staaten hier
anwesend ob alle so freiwillig ist die
große Frage viele sind sicherlich auch
einfach gezwungen zu kommen weil sie
Russland nach wie vor brauchen dazu
gehört zum Beispiel Armenien dazu gehört
Kirgistan auch kasachstan hat den
Präsidenten geschickt das finde ich auch
sehr erstaunlich selbst in der Nacht ist
der Turkmene noch gekommen heute früh
noch Lukaschenko dazu gekommen also ist
eine ganze Reihe sieben Staatschef
insgesamt die hier sind und Putin hat
das sehr betont am Schluss und hat am
sehr am Schluss noch mal betont wie es
stehen alle eingeeint auf auf derselben
Seite also ob das alle wirklich so gut
finden die da mit ihm standen das weiß
ich auch nicht wir hatten schon hier im
Studios konnten sie wahrscheinlich mir
nicht mitverfolgen auch noch mal über
die Rolle von dem Verteidigungsminister
der hat ja die Parade abgenommen
gesprochen welche Stellung hat der noch
gerade nach den heftigen Attacken von
prigoshi in dem Chef der wagnergruppe
vor einigen Tagen der man muss es ja
wirklich mal so sagen den
Verteidigungsminister in aller
Öffentlichkeit übelst beschimpft hat
große Glaskugel kann ich mich hier aus
Moskau auch nicht so richtig gut zu
äußern alles was Armee Verteidigung vor
allem Kritik an der Armee betrifft kann
schnell ausgelegt werden als
Diskreditierung der Armee deswegen kann
ich da auch nicht viel mehr zu sagen als
das was sie wollen wahrscheinlich auch
schon vermutet haben es ist sehr schwer
reinzuschauen in diese Glaskugel noch
scheint Putin anschau gut festzuhalten
aber sicher ist sein Posten sicherlich
nicht mehr im Vergleich mit dem was was
wir noch vor ein paar Jahren hier erlebt
haben wie eng die beiden doch sind ob
das immer noch so ist große Frage wie
sind die Stimmung allgemein in Russland
auch angesichts der Sanktionen dieses
Jahr gegen Russland gibt das wird ja
immer wieder auf der einen Seite beklagt
von führenden Politikerinnen und
Politikern in Russland aber auf der
anderen Seite heißt auch immer
eigentlich schaden und sie Sanktionen
gar nicht wird wirklich wie ist das so
wie würden sie das momentan einordnen
also die Sanktionen sind ein weites Feld
man sieht schon sehr deutlicher
Resultate dieser Sanktionen aber
tatsächlich betreffen sie längst nicht
alle Menschen und sind hier auch nicht
so das Thema wenn man heute morgen durch
die Stadt fertig habe das eben gemacht
da stehen die Leute wirklich in Mengen
an der Rute die die Parade später nach
Ende nehmen wird der wird ja die Technik
dann abziehen raus aus Moskau an der
Straße haben sich viele Menschen bereits
aufgestellt viele die auch sagen dass
sie das alles richtig und gut finden
aber das sind eben genau die die auch zu
solchen Paraden dann kommen wenn man
Umfragen macht dann stellt man doch
immer wieder fest also auch mit der
Kamera rausgeht dass viele einfach
weglaufen und gar nicht reden wollen
viele auch sagen wenn ich ihn sagen
würde was ich denke dann könnten sie das
nicht senden und ähm manche natürlich
das ganze auch sehr loben ich glaube es
ist tatsächlich sehr sehr schwierig im
Moment wirklich ein Meinungsbild zu
erheben ich denke immer noch dass eine
Mehrheit wahrscheinlich hinter all dem
steht aber es sind nicht so viele wie
uns in auch soziologischen Umfragen
präsentiert werden dass es da bis zu 80
Prozent hinter Putins Kriegskurs stehen
das zweifle ich doch an doch war eine
vielleicht abschließende Frage man sieht
ja hier viele junge Leute auf dem Bild
die Soldaten die jetzt auch die Parade
an der an Putin vorbei marschieren über
den Roten Platz aber insgesamt sind ja
das würde gerade in den letzten Tagen
immer wieder auch in deutschen Medien
noch mal erwähnt haben ja teilweise
100.000 das Land verlassen viele wurden
eingezogen zur Armee macht sich das
bemerkbar
also zu Beginn der
mobilenmachung hier war plötzlich die
Stadt Leer und zwar nicht weil alle
mobil gemacht worden wären sondern weil
sie sich tatsächlich versteckt haben man
muss sich das so vorstellen da sind ja
wirklich Leute von den werämtern auch
militärische Leute in der Uniform durch
die metros gezogen und durch die also
U-Bahn Station durch die Stadt und haben
Leute angehalten ob sie sich melden beim
Lehramt also das da sind wirklich viele
einfach in die dutschen gegangen oder
aber eben außer Landes geflohen das war
sehr deutlich auch abends in den Bars
saßen nur Frauen das hat mir eine
Freundin erzählt die ja viel abends
unterwegs ist und ähm das hat sich ein
bisschen wieder geändert viele sind
zurückgekommen aber natürlich
spürt man das sehr deutlich auch viele
junge Leute gerade mit einer guten
Ausbildung die jetzt überlegen ob sie
mich doch noch wieder rausgehen das ist
schon sehr deutlich es waren übrigens
heute
530 Teilnehmer der spezialoperation auf
dem Platz wurde auch groß betont die
wieder mitmarschiert sein sollen das
ganze ist immer noch nicht sehr beliebt
denke ich dort teilzunehmen viele Leute
machen das aus Geldgründen und jetzt
sind auch in Moskau mittlerweile Plakate
aufgetaucht wo man aktiv wirbt für die
Teilnahme also für die für das sich
einschreiben als Berufssoldat früher sah
man das nur in der Provinz jetzt gibt's
das auch hier das rückt alles näher und
ich glaube viele machen sich da auch
Gedanken und das letzte was ich
vielleicht dazu noch sagen möchte eine
neue Mobilmachung wird man sich hier
sehr gut überlegen zumindest das
offiziell zu machen denn man hat doch
also Schätzungen gehen bis zu einer
Millionen Menschen verloren die das Land
verlassen haben viele mögen inzwischen
wiedergekommen sein aber es ist schon
doch sehr spürbar deswegen ist man da
sicherlich sehr vorsichtig
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung
direkt nach der Rede von Vladimir
ja und die Parade geht hier weiter und
ich habe auch noch zwei Gäste hier im
Studio wo man ganz scharrenko von der
Deutschen Welle haben vor in der Ruck
hat eben gerade noch mal auch noch mal
erwähnt man merkt schon durchaus die
Sanktionen man merkt durchaus auch schon
dass die jungen Leute fehlen die
entweder ins Militär abgezogen werden
oder eben auch geflohen sind ja ins
Ausland in die Nachbarländer
wie lange glauben sie bleibt denn die
Unterstützung für diesen Krieg so wie
sie sich momentan zeigt erhalten ich
glaube ähm die wird noch auf jeden Fall
ein zwei Jahre so stark bleiben wir
jetzt vielleicht länger wir wissen nicht
wie lange der Krieg dauert das ist einer
dieser Kriege die ähm nicht nach einem
Jahr vorbei sind
obwohl Russland natürlich als anders
geplant hat aber was die Unterstützung
der russischen Gesellschaft dann
betrifft glaube ich dass das System
relativ stabil ist und große Teile
Bevölkerung hinter Wladimir Putin stehen
und hinter diesem Krieg auch es gibt
einen Kern der leidenschaftlich für
diesen Krieg ist
je nach Schätzungen zwischen 20 30
Prozent vielleicht es gibt eine Mehrheit
die schweigt und passiv diesen Krieg
unterstützt und es gibt ganz wenige
Leute die diesen gegen diesen Krieg sind
und die meisten die gegendenkrieg sind
sind tatsächlich geflüchtet sind jetzt
im Ausland in Nachbarländern teilweise
im Westen aber die meisten in den
Nachbarländern mehr als eine Million
Russen und Russinnen haben und das Land
verlassen vor allem als Putin die
teilmobilisierung also hier ist das ja
ob das wirklich Teil Mobilisierung war
oder nicht wissen wenn ich genau auf
jeden Fall seit September 22 haben ja
hunderttausende Russland verlassen und
das merkt man das spürt man aber dadurch
dass man so groß ist oder 140 Millionen
Menschen kann es solche Schläge
verkraften abfedern und die russische
Wirtschaft ist eine Marktwirtschaft
anders dass die sowjetische
Planwirtschaft ist also deutlich
resilienter und wir sehen jetzt auch
dass die Auswirkungen die am Anfang sehr
spürbar waren teilweise durch die sehr
hohen Preise für Öl und Gas am
ausgeglichen wurden man spürt natürlich
die Sanktionen immer mehr aber
andererseits passt sich auch die
russische Wirtschaft immer mehr diesem
Zustand an den Putin ja eigentlich auch
wollte er wollte eine abkupplung
Russlands von der Weltwirtschaft
natürlich nicht komplett aber er wollte
Unabhängigkeit vom Besten und das
passiert jetzt sie sehen jetzt hier
immer noch die Bilder der Parade die
vorbei marschierenden sind das
vermutlich die Waffen Gattung aber es
ist sozusagen die jetzt bei Wladimir
Putin sozusagen an der Tribüne vorbei
marschieren
heranzie sie hatten das vorhin mal so
angedeutet er hat ja relativ wenig über
die Ukraine gesprochen eigentlich in
seiner Rede hat ja auch die Ukraine als
Spielball der Mächte eigentlich
bezeichnet aber auf der anderen Seite
sind es dort wieder Nazis Neonazis aus
aller Welt was hatte das in konkrete von
Wladimir Putin für eine Aufgabe die sind
Neonazis die ja immer wieder bedient
also zunächst einmal ist festzuhalten
dass er eindeutig gesagt hat dass der
Westen Schuld an diesem Krieg ist also
an der Aggression Russlands weil sie die
Ukraine für ihre Zwecke als ihr Werkzeug
missbraucht haben das ist der eine Teil
dabei und der zweite Teil das ist eine
Linie die zieht sich durchaus den
Zweiten Weltkrieg ist der Kampf gegen
den Nationalsozialismus und es ist ja
für mich sage ich ganz deutlich an
Treppenwitz der Weltgeschichte dass man
den Präsidenten die Ukraine der jüdische
Abstammung ist als ein
Nationalsozialisten bezeichnet hier wird
eine bestimmte Maske über die Ukraine
gestülpt von Seiten von Putin und auf
diese Art und Weise eine gewisse
Gefolgschaft des russischen Volkes auf
der einen Seite aber auch die
historische Kette vom Zweiten Weltkrieg
von dem erfolgreichen Kampf der
Veteranen zu dem Erfolg der
sonderoperation in der Ukraine heute
herzustellen das ist ein geschickter
aber leicht durchschaubar Schachzug der
aber möglicherweise bei der russischen
Bevölkerung tatsächlich in einigen
Bereichen zumindest auf fruchtbaren
Boden fällt wir reden gleich noch mal
weiter aber ich möchte jetzt noch mal zu
einem anderen Thema kommen was
eigentlich das gleiche Thema ist nur wir
werden ein bisschen die Städte wechseln
nämlich von Moskau nach Kiew in die
Ukraine die
EU-Kommissarin Ursula von der Leyen die
kommissionspräsidentin sie ist der hier
sehen wir die Bilder heute morgen in
Moskau ein pardon in der Ukraine in Kiew
angekommen und trifft sich vermutlich
zur Stunde mit dem Präsidenten Ukraine
silenski zwei wichtige Themen hatte sie
bereits gesagt hat sie im Gepäck es geht
natürlich einmal um die Frage der
Unterstützung der Ukraine militärisch da
ist ja jetzt ein großes munitionspaket
der verabschiedet worden und zum anderen
geht es natürlich auch um den
EU-Beitritt der Ukraine und die
Möglichkeiten dort das sind die beiden
Themen so hat Ursachen von alleine
verlauten lassen die Sie vorab schon mal
mit im Gepäck hat natürlich der
EU-Beitritt der wird noch auf sich
warten lassen das ist zumindest das was
man aus vielen Ecken Europas auch von
vielen politischen Führern in Europa
innerhalb der EU gehört hat gestern gab
es Feierlichkeiten in Kiew der 8 mai er
soll ja künftig der Nationalfeiertag in
Kiel werden nicht der 9 mai früher hat
man auch den 9 mai in der Ukraine
begangen damit soll jetzt Schluss sein
dass es zumindest der Vorschlag des
Präsidenten silensk